we begin this half hour with an
unprecedented debate over medical ethics
and justice this week a maryland family
filed what they say is the first of many
lawsuits against major biotechnology and
medical firms the descendants of
henrietta lacks say cells harvested from
their mother decades ago and without her
consent have led to untold billions of
dollars in profits
none of which they have seen
in vitro fertilization the aids cocktail
chemotherapy drugs
zebra there isn't a person alive who
hasn't benefited from your mother's
cells the story made famous by the book
and movie the immortal life of henrietta
lacks might feel like science fiction
but could soon look like a courtroom
thriller in 1951 lacks a black woman
suffering from cervical cancer had her
cells taken without her consent by
doctors at johns hopkins university in
baltimore scientists discovered her
cells which they dubbed hela cells were
the first that could be successfully
cloned outside the human body hela cells
have since been at the foundation of
countless medical breakthroughs which
have generated billions of dollars for
biotech and pharmaceutical companies
over the years
but now lacks his family is suing a
lawsuit filed this week against biotech
firm thermo fisher scientific claims
lacks was the victim of a racially
unjust medical system for some reason
feels they have intellectual property
rights over his grandmother's sales that
were illegally stolen from her body this
has never been done before there is no
way to know what the result will be
cbs news legal analyst ricky clemens
says the family may have an uphill climb
in court if there was ever a good time
to bring this lawsuit
it's in this time because of the
upheaval in society about social justice
thermo fisher has not commented on the
lawsuit but laxa's family says it's
planning to sue even more companies in
the future
john hopkins university which is not
named in the suit maintains it never
sold or profited from lax's cells when i
started off as a scientist in the lab
when i trained at hopkins we talked
about hela cells all the time
they were integral to all of the
experiments we did cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus says medical
ethics have shifted in the 70 years
since lax's cells were taken since that
time
patients have been consented and is
their option whether to participate in
research and what will happen to their
tissue after surgery before that point
though it wasn't on the radar screen of
researchers if you're the defendant in
this case how would you advise your
client well the first thing that you are
going to say if you are advising the
pharmaceutical company is
this is a case that you may want to
settle
and ricky calls this creative
lawyering the kind we saw in brown
versus board of education roe versus
wade and she believes this could have
far-reaching implications in the medical
community well if you think about those
previous cases obviously that creative
lawyering led to some serious change and
it's a good point though they were not
given the option before now they are
given yeah they are you've come a long
way